je pourrais vous faire un talk sur le
stress pendant deux heures depuis
quelques temps j'entends souvent ce
genre de phrase me concernant toi tu as
de la chance
toi tu es né sous une bonne étoile toit
de toutes les façons avec les relations
que tu as c'est sûr que tu réussis 1 où
tu as une pétroleuse tu as peur de rien
eh bien c'est faux entièrement faux
permettez moi de vous retracer ma vie à
l'envers et je vais vous montrer ma
bonne étoile
certains l'appellent dieu d'autres une
d'autres un destin et puis certains le
karma moi je l'appelle ce grand farceur
la vie est un voyage et comme chaque
voyage il est un point de départ et un
sac à dos à faire mon sac à dos ce grand
farceur
voilà ce qu'il m'a mis à l'intérieur des
briques des grosses briques le premier
naître dans une banlieue parisienne mais
pas neuilly sur seine issy les
moulineaux gonesse vous connaissez
gonesse même le concorde s'est scratché
sur cette ville et puis une barre
d'immeuble 6000 habitants 20% de chômage
18 nationalités différentes
et puis pour s'amuser va me rajouter une
autre brique un divorce des parents
assez difficile à la kramer contre
kramer et puis quelque temps après il va
me rajouter une autre brique ma mère
tombe amoureuse d'une femme
il paraît que c'est pas bien c'est
d'actualité à aimer une autre femme
c'est moche et puis peut-être la brique
la plus douloureuse
la mort de mon père quand je suis
adolescentes mais une mort brutale
puisque il se suicide
et puis à 20 ans il décide de me mettre
encore une plus grosse brique il me dit
que je n'aurais probablement jamais
d'enfant alors voilà qu'est ce que j'en
fait ce sac à dos je le laisse je veux
bien obligé de porter avec moi c'est mon
histoire
alors moi j'ai choisi d'être heureuse
parce que ça c'est pas mon histoire je
ne suis responsable de rien ni de
l'environnement où je suis né ni de
l'histoire de mes parents et ce déclic
ce choc
je les lui sur un graffiti sur ce
graffiti est indiquée l'espace d'une vie
est le même qu on le passe en pleurant
ou en chantant l'espace d'une vie est le
même qu on le passe en pleurant en
chantant n'est pas content lieu quand
même et ça a été le déclic
c'était le choc je me suis dit hors de
question de suivre ces chemins préétabli
tout destiné pour moi alors le choix des
possibles qu'est ce que c'est moi je
suis fier d'être non banlieue parisienne
mais madeleine de proust eux s'appelle
m'a fait le colombo le thibout jane ça
m'a donné une ouverture d'esprit
ça m'a donné envie de voyager et à 17
ans je suis parti en afrique
toujours avec le même sac à dos à mais
beaucoup plus léger a le choix des
possibles depuis je suis petit on me dit
que je suis une contrainte que je
n'arriverai pas à l'école et on a mis au
fond de la classe
j'étais coincé entre farid chenoune et
gérard boube r autant vous dire que
j'étais une menace sur l'équipe de foot
de saint-etienne mais par contre au
niveau des tables de multiplication
c'était pas ça et puis tout cela toute
ma scolarité on a mis au fond de la
classe et jusqu'à ce qu'une professeure
de français me demande de venir au
premier rang 3e et m'offre un livre ce
livre c'est la cicatrice de bruce lowery
l'appareil je suis tombée amoureuse de
la lecture et de la littérature arts et
la littérature m'a apporté l'espoir le
rêve est une culture
je suis comme jean noël je n'ai pas mon
bac et je suis fier quand même d'avoir
réussi professionnellement
le choix des possibles le mot sexualité
de ma mère alors nous amis de la manif
pour tous nos fins pas mes amis à moi en
tous les cas mais disent que ce n'est
pas déjà ce qui n'est pas bien c'est le
regard des autres moi je ne demande pas
ma mère ce qu'elle fait dans sa chambre
à coucher
par contre je laime et quand on a une
mère épanouie et heureuse à imaginer
quand on en a deux la mère avait honte
sur vous imaginez il ya 30 ans dire dans
une banlieue parisienne refaire savions
plus avec une black le regard des autres
alors à 25 ans pour libérer la parole
j'ai été manifestée à la gay pride pour
elle j'avais un panneau avec marc et ma
mère est homo elle en a honte moi j'en
suis fier
depuis ça a libéré sa parole elle a fait
son coming out et maintenant c'est la
première à la gay pride est reconduit
même un char a le choix des possibles la
partie la plus douloureuse c'est le
souci d'un papa a 14 ans quand on essaye
de se construire et que l'homme qui est
censé le plus vous aimez vous abandonne
c'est très douloureux mais ce n'est pas
mon histoire non plus je pense que lui
n'a pas eu le choix des possibles moi je
laime mais il était hors de question que
cet abandon je le fasse porter sur le
poids ou sur les épaules des hommes que
j'allais rencontrer dans ma vie voilà je
suis plus légères je suis plus forte
j'arrive dans la vie professionnelle je
choisis de faire des études d'hôtellerie
et de restauration
et puis là je m'aperçois que c'est un
monde étriqué assez misogyne dont je
j'arrête je change de vie
un jour je me présente un poste
d'hôtesse avec mon cv sans piller
banlieue et là je vois une femme qui me
m'interroge et je vois tellement de
mépris dans ses yeux et dans sa voix que
tout mon être se rebelle et je lui dis
qu'il est hors de question qu'elle me
parle comme cela ce fut mon premier acte
de pétroleuses je suis sorti de son
bureau furieuse et là dans la course je
bute sur un homme andré fournet cet
homme me regarde menant de les coller me
demande les raisons de ma colère je les
lui donne
il sourit et décide de me donner ma
chance
ce fut mon mentor c'est lui c'est grâce
à lui que maintenant je fais ce métier
il m'a transmis l'amour de
l'événementiel et cinq ans après cette
rencontre
j'ai été responsable de tout bercy
exploit je tombe amoureuse je pars vivre
à montpellier là encore je refais ma vie
à zéro je ne connais personne personne
j'ai même regardé sur une carte où se
situe et montpellier et je décide de
monter une société en pleine période de
crise
pourquoi faire en 2008 et là j'avais un
rêve d'enfant mettre mes compétences au
service d'une bonne cause parce qu'il
était important pour moi
avec lemon que l'on m'avait tendu de
données et de rendre ce que l'on m'avait
apporté et je décide de monter une
association qui s'appelle la
montpelliéraine a du coeur
c'était une évidence que je parle des
femmes avec toutes les femmes autour de
moi et j'ai choisi le cancer du sein
je me suis renseigné alors j'ai rien
inventé un il existe des cancers des
courses de cancer du sein partout en
france et dans le monde
mais quand je me suis renseigné j'ai vu
qu'il y avait aussi la ségrégation
les hommes ne pouvaient pas courir et il
fallait demander un certificat médical
aux participantes
moi j'ai refusé il était hors de
question que les femmes malades soient
bénéficiaires de cet événement je
voulais qu'elle soit actrice et puis
surtout je voulais que leurs familles
puissent participer leurs maris leurs
enfants parce que ça passe aussi par là
la prévention alors levée de boucliers
total personne n'a voulu m'aider on me
disait ce vous avez 250 personnes
estimez-vous heureuse mais moi 250
personnes je fermais ma boîte et je
vendais ma maison puisque j'avais mis
tous mes assedic à l'intérieur de cette
course je ne voulais rien demandé à
personne je voulais absolument la faire
et grâce à la montpelliéraine
cette solidarité pareil j'ai décidé de
la faire le jour de la fête des mères
alors on m'a dit que ça ne serait que ça
ne fonctionnerait pas et ça fonctionne
aujourd'hui la montpelliéraine ses 6000
participants
j'ai voulu en faire un événement festif
rock'n'roll et surtout qu'on ne pleure
pas dans les chaumières et un moment de
partage
et puis grâce à la montpelliéraine j'ai
rencontré des personnes magnifiques dont
le professeur lamarque
alors un petit rappel le professeur
lamarque c'est le papa des mâts mobil 1
c'est grâce à lui et georges frêche
qu'il ya maintenant des mâts mobile qui
traverse toute la région et qui vont au
devant des fans pour se faire dépister
ce professeur de la marque me dit me
sensibilise me sensibilise à la
précocité des cancers dessin du sein
chez les jeunes filles 10 % des femmes
qui ont un cancer du sein au moins 40
ans alors je peux être que vous ne le
savez pas mais il ya très peu de
personnes qui le savent moi j'ai pensé à
mes petites soeurs de banlieue à aux
femmes qui n'avaient pas cette
information
et je me suis demandé pourquoi les gens
pourquoi personne ne communiquait
pourquoi aucune association de
communiquer sur ce fléau a donc j'ai
voulu que la pressante par là
mais pour en parler à la presse il
fallait que j'organise un événement qui
puisse les attirer alors avec 20
pétroleuses on en voyait nos soutiens
gorge j'étais sûr que les hommes
allaient venir effectivement toute la
presse est venue régionales et
nationales pendant une minute
nous avons montré notre poitrine place
de la comédie en plein après midi je
voulais absolument que le plus de
personnes possibles puissent nous voir
et ça a fonctionné
l'information a tourné en france on est
passé un peu partout et le message est
passé
après cette opération choc place de la
comédie
il ya une jeune femme de 27 ans qui est
venu voir et qui m'a raconté son
histoire bouleversante
elle m'a raconté son cancer du sein elle
m'a remercié parce que je l'avais
reconnue parce que j'avais parlé de son
malheur de sa détresse parce que c'était
vraiment ça qu'elle vivait et avec son
accord avec elle j'ai décidé de monter
une exposition photographique et de
montrer dix jeunes femmes qui ont été
touchés par cette maladie
ça a été compliqué parce que nous avons
mis un an et demi à trouver des jeunes
femmes qui puissent et qui veulent bien
témoigner il y en a sur une vingtaine y
en a huit qui se sont désistés une qui
est décédé entre temps et puis disent
qu'ils ont continué et qui ont bien
voulu témoigner
cette exposition j'ai voulu la faire
comme une exposition d'art parce que je
savais très bien que si je parlais de
cancer à des jeunes
personne ne viendrait je suis comme le
professeur de la marque je veux parler
aux bien portants c'était à eux qu'il
faut parler pour les sensibiliser au
dépistage et donc on a fait des photos
avec des photographes et sur chaque
photo il y avait un recto et au verso
sur le recto c'était la jeune fille sexy
dans son univers et nous avons exposé
dans une salle d'arts ça a été aussi
très compliqué d'avoir cette salle parce
qu'on voulait me mettre dans une maison
de la prévention ou dans un hôpital mais
moi je voulais une salle d'arts j'ai
vraiment insisté et puis je n'arrivais
pas à avoir cette autorisation est
je venais d'accoucher ça faisait six
jours que j'avais accouché j'ai été voir
un directeur de cabinet qui m'a compris
quand il a vu les photos il a eu les
larmes aux yeux
il m'a dit je vous donne mon accord
allez-y mon bébé les six jours je
l'allaitait et ça a été très émouvant et
donc nous avons fait cette exposition de
jeunes filles et je les remercie
vraiment d'avoir bien voulu témoigner
parce qu'aujourd'hui ce sont devenus des
femmes beaucoup plus forte parce
qu'elles ont été reconnus ces femmes
aujourd'hui on la folie de devenir aussi
chef d'entreprise et elles font ce
qu'elles ont toujours voulu faire le
choix des possibles c'est mettre ses
compétences au service des autres c'est
suivre son propre chemin
et voilà j'ai voulu témoigner sur ça et
puis la dernière chose on a dit qu'un
jour enfin que j'aurais sûrement aucune
chance d'avoir des enfants
aujourd'hui j'ai trois petites filles
magnifiques grâce à un médecin qu'on
appelle le médecin qui faisait des bébés
en parlant lorsque je suis arrivé dans
son cabinet il est ce dans un tout petit
village à côté montpellier je suis
arrivé dans son cabinet il y avait que
des livres et pas du tout de matériel
gynécologique il n'y avait que des
livres 1
déjà ça m'a parlé il m'a demandé ce que
j'aimais le plus au monde
je lui dis les voyages l'inde il m'a lu
une histoire je les trouve un peu
bizarre ce médecin
un mois après j'étais enceinte j'ai
appelé ma première fille comme lui
s'appelait jean j'appelais ma fille
jeanne heureusement qui s'appelait pas
germain parce que la pauvre et avec mes
filles pour mes filles et pour tous les
petits enfants qui sont derniers au
dernier rang des classes j'ai monté un
magazine un magazine gratuit un magazine
pour enfants parce que je veux que la
culture aille vers tout le monde et
c'est pour ça que ce magazine qui
s'appelle nine pas ce que ça veut dire
enfants et écrit aussi par eux et puis
pour terminer je voudrais remercier le
tedx de montpellier parce que donner la
parole à une ancienne bègue c'est aussi
ça le choix des possibles merci